Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to. Oh, I
don't know. How about David from Regina?
Regina, Saskatchewan.
Speaker 3: Regina.
Speaker 1: Is that true?
That's how it's pronounced.
Speaker 3: Yes, it is. Actually, there's a fine
line called experience, Regina. Jimmy Fallon
actually has. He's covered that before.
Speaker 1: But, David,
welcome to China. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Thanks for having me. Yeah,
I guess my question today, I had a caller a few
weeks back who is talking about gender and sex,
and I feel like something's happening a lot where
the right is conflating these two things a lot.
Right? Like they don't understand the difference
between biological sex and gender expression,
right? Yep. You know, while they're related,
they're not the same thing. So I guess my
question is like, how the hell do we even start
to have that discussion? Like, I feel like.
We can't even have a discussion about the
issue without people understanding what
that even means, if that makes sense. Like.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I don't know. Like, I feel
like. So the call in the call you're thinking of,
I made an attempt to try to explain to the caller
who maybe was just unwilling rather than unable to
see. I gave the example of the rock and then the
fashion designer, Isaac Mizrahi. And I think that
in a respectful way, I explained, You understand
these are both males, right? We're talking about
biological males. They were born male. We're
talking, they're both male. The rock expresses
gender in a much more stereotypically masculine
way, whereas Isaac Mizrahi expresses gender in a
much more feminine way, like. So the idea was to
get him to think, okay, right. Penis, penis. I see
that. And then here's one presentation and here's
another presentation. Oh, there is more than just
the genital feel like I tried. You know, I think
sometimes it's like you've got to use examples
like that to maybe get them to think about these
things. But I agree with you. A lot of them do.
They they don't seem to want to get it, honestly.
Speaker 3: Well, and that's just it,
right? I think. And I think honestly, like
if they would just take even just like
an introductory level course in like any
of these social science topics, like we've
been we've talked about this for decades and
decades and like, there's not there's really no
debate about the difference between these things
anymore. Right? So, yeah, but it's scary stuff,
like it has a real impact. And, you know, we're
definitely frightened up here in Canada watching
your Supreme Court do all these weird things. So.
Yeah. I hope I hope you guys can turn that
around with the next election for sure.
Speaker 1: Well, let's hope so. We are. I am on
board with with your now, how is is this an issue
that's even really discussed where you are or is
it just like people don't really talk about this?
Speaker 3: You know, I'm in Saskatchewan and we're
kind of the most rightwing place in Canada, so
like it's a conservative haven here, but as
a country as a whole, I mean, it's disgust
and there's like kind of a fringe movement of
people who want to do the whole MAGA thing here.
But I would say as a majority, I don't see that
happening. I don't see that movement getting a lot
of traction, even even here in the conservative
kind of Bible Belt of Canada. It's it's well,
it's more popular here. Some of these ideas,
they're still not getting enough traction to
like influence a lot of policy and and that
kind of thing. So I think I'm hoping we're
safe. I mean, I knock on wood, right?
Speaker 1: So I hope that that's the
case. David, I appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: Yeah, thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: All right. Great to hear from our
friendly neighbors to the north, of course.